so week after week we are watching you
make kelly cry Wow what is going through
your head when you're watching her
starting to tears
welcome you you know honestly it makes
me want to tear up because I like making
people tear up like it's it's sad but
it's also kind of cool like the feeling
that I'm making people feel like
different types of emotions so just
seeing my coach who has taught me
through this whole experience cry
because of something I did is just
really awesome and I know she's giving
you a plethora of advice this whole
season but what is one thing that you
maybe still haven't gotten the chance to
tell her yeah well I really want to like
tell her sincerely thank you so much
because not many teenagers get this
opportunity to work with Kelly Clarkson
one-on-one week by week so it's really
awesome and I just want to thank her so
so much for all she's done for me what's
been your favorite memory of working
with Mary my favorite memory of working
with Kelly's just how easy it is to be
yourself around her she's so what you
see on TV is what you get
she's just so open and down-to-earth and
real and you can be yourself around her
it's not like talking to a celebrity
it's like talking to just your sister
she's really awesome if you win tomorrow
what's the first thing you're gonna do
well my family's here in town so we
probably go go get like dinner or
something and probably a milkshake
because I'm the same way from Dairy you
know cuz singers I would probably just
celebrate with my family
just to go back home and hang out with
the whole town that's been voting me
through in supporting me in a dream duet
besides singing with Kelly Loretta Lynn
Dolly Parton Carrie Underwood I have a
whole bunch describe this whole
experience this whole experience has
been surreal she's been so incredible